many many people very very triggered by
the news that producer louis MO tommy
will be moving on from the david pakman
show and seeking warmer and less urban
refuge than what exists here in boston
massachusetts I've compiled some of the
more interesting comments that have been
made in response here is just a few how
do you feel about your boyfriend leaving
David you will be alone in your mom's
garage another comment also it the end
it's weird to hear that Lois is leaving
and then write in and say hey also David
are you gay I'm just curious you kind of
give that vibe love the videos ok that's
very strange uh great comic from Dan
Burke uh we'll get to that a little bit
later yeah we posted a comic about Louis
leaving from Denver I don't dislike
Louis but really all he ever said was
yeah and agree with David another
comment you agree with Louis Boston
sucks another comment poor David is
going to have to find himself another
sycophant is it sick of inter sycophant
psycho fans is it that's what i call it
I will I stand corrected uh I think
Louis contributed to the show
significantly and enjoyed his
perspective maybe I was a little biased
because I think he's very good-looking
that can bias people ring-a-ding-ding up
be the Louis you want to be in the world
a great advice to Louis up poor David or
that that ones on there twice that's
weird i must have made a mistake there
ok and we have a few more comments to
show you oh thank god i may actually be
able to watch the whole show now Louis
has a face made for radio uh another
comment I like Luis as a person and I
hope he is much happier wherever he
winds up another comment unsubscribing
louis was the best part of the show
somebody wrote in saying jeez if I
didn't know better I would think I was
listening to a much older person
possibly one who is retiring a bit
unusual for someone is eight yet the
reasons you're citing are the types of
reasons you hear from a 67 year old
who's retiring well uh I I don't feel
that old but um I don't know what to say
I guess when it's a 20 degrees out maybe
I do if you made him a proper
respectable part of the show I'm
sure he would have left also sorry to
see David go but hope you find your new
verano uh yeah I'm not leaving some be a
few people Louis seeing the announcement
that you're leaving thinking I'm leaving
uh another comment David keep the look
you have in this particular video the
haircut and scruff is really working
I've never seen you look so handsome
blue is definitely your color this
person clearly not affected at all by
the announcement that Louis leaving when
that was their reaction uh second to
last comment we'll all miss you David
again I am NOT leaving Louis is the one
who's leaving and to cap it from the egg
man Louis is leaving because of a love
triangle between Dave cute intern and
him okay I don't know who the cute
intern is is that John he's talking
about Rachel no doubt okay who is not an
intern all right and then lastly I do
want to put this up for you we got a
great new comic from Dan Burke who does
david pakman show comics the drawings
are absolutely fantastic and we're
putting it up for people who are
watching with us and it's basically a
recreation of his this is dan's
interpretation of how the conversation
about Louis leaving went uh and I
encourage you to check this out directly
I won't read it all to you that's a
little weird but the gist of it is that
Dan thought I was oddly jubilant about
Louis leaving and also sort of ridiculed
the questions I asked to Luis about his
leaving and uh also sort of exaggerated
the the comical nature of Louis's
reasons for leaving I love these comics
from Dan Burke they're really really
good very funny yes